donc je suis vraiment je suis tellement contente pour toi qu'est-ce que ça
signifie pour toi de recevoir
c'est notre moment à Paris, je veux dire, c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable ouais mon esprit
est assez époustouflé pour être honnête avec
toi je tu sais  c'est juste que c'est
un monde dans lequel les gens comme moi ne
vivent généralement pas et donc je me sens
extrêmement béni et chanceux ouais
ouais mais pour recevoir celui-ci pour
ce projet, je veux dire Olivier Assayas avec
Juliette Binoche qui sont chez Canon en  en
mai avec ce film et maintenant c'est une
histoire spécifique, je veux dire ce film et
c'est notre truc très spécifique pour vous
ouais absolument vous savez Charles Gomez
qui a produit le film m'a fait découvrir
aux gens que les meilleurs
cinéastes américains sont ceux qui prennent des risques
et ceux qui le sont tu sais n'agissent pas
par peur et et et c'est très rare
aux USA alors qu'ici c'est c'est ça
l'esprit de faire du cinéma
c'est ça c'est ça tu sais c'est pas
difficile à trouver et donc ça fait juste un
beaucoup de sens que je suis là pour ça avec
lui et avec Olivier avec Juliette
c'est qu'ils englobent tout ce que
j'admire dans le cinéma tellement génial celui-ci
Juliette Binoche
Juliette est toujours comme une référence pour toi
je veux dire en tant qu'actrice ouais absolument la
première  la fois où j'ai vu je ne sais pas quel
est le titre français mais les amoureux sur le pont j'aime
bien je je n'aurais jamais pensé
pouvoir faire quelque chose comme ça être en
présence de quelque chose comme ça quand
je suis monté sur le plateau avec elle et c'est juste  c'est
en quelque sorte tombé entre nous et c'était naturel
et ça a marché j'étais euh je devais je devais
me rappeler tous les jours c'est comme si c'était
la même fille tu aimerais peut-être
faire un autre film avec le
réalisateur français on trouve un bon sujet bien
sûr  et peut-être qu'un jour en français
je ne sais pas c'est vraiment dur
mec je dois te dire que j'ai essayé je sais je sais je
sais
mais quelque chose que tu veux peut-être faire un
jour on pourra parler en français dans le
film français ouais
merci beaucoup  beaucoup en corrélation
Kristen merci